let's talk about what story is not
right well there are many things that
story is not and it also relates back to
this idea that story is better than the
real
so one of the things that story is not
is that it is not
a literal day in the life it is not
just a um you know plod
through the day and i say i get my
coffee and i wake up in the morning and
i
go to work there's something that there
is a core action or a core problem that
is bigger or better than the real
that ties it in that can tie it into an
everyday situation but it's not just
those little everyday
moments and i and i just wanted to to
throw in there you know boyhood
was my favorite movie of the year and i
think that you know it breaks all of
these rules
um but the reason why it works is
that it's not just a day in the life or
recounting but it
it's it's this also this device of
having happened over
12 years that makes it so so fascinating
and so there are exceptions to this rule
but on the whole
these are the things that that people
should avoid when they're
approaching their stories another one is
random musings
you know this is uh you know
it seems to me where it's very
pretentious where you have some
characters sitting in a diner and
somebody goes
ketchup what's that about right that
and then the movie just kind of moves
through people saying that and you know
it's funny to point out that
people think they're profound when
they're not once in a while
but if your whole movie is just kind of
like ketchup what's that about
do the audience after about 20 minutes
if that long will go what
do i need to be here for this what is
this and and it feels
very pretentious uh kind of just fishing
around well these are just some people
who really they had one
germ of an idea but they really didn't
think this through it doesn't have any
progression
story is also it's not a straight line
it needs to go up
and down and around and there needs to
be highs and lows
and like
in the same way that it's not a day in
the life it's not
it's it's not just a straightforward
telling of events
you know another one is story is not a
fascinating place or
even a really cool event
so we get pitches like this all the time
people like i want to write a story
about or i have a movie about
a nuclear submarine getting stuck on the
bottom of the ocean
and we go and watch the story what's the
story
and they're like a nuclear submarine's
on the bottom of the ocean it's like
that's not a story a story is when you
start telling me
and what the character stakes are you
know with that you know so
another one is oh wow i went to this
amazing village in china
and you know it's at the village where
they make
you know the dragons for the for the
festivals
it's amazing and my my movie is like
that village
it's like that's not a story that's an
arena
so we're constantly having to help
writers distinguish
a really cool arena you know or an
interesting
you know kind of event from being a
story those things aren't stored
or chicago in the 20s you know
again great great arena but you have
nothing until you have your characters
doing something that's going to move
your story forward
how soon do you introduce conflict i'm
seeing sometimes conflict is within the
first minute sometimes
yes sometimes longer what what do you
think
one exercise that we do with our clients
is we have them make a list of
every possible conflict that could ever
happen to their character
and and then you know try to come up
with 20 things and then we say
okay now come up with 10 more and then
come up with 10 more
and now put them put it all in your
script see how much conflict you can add
to your script
and that's a really common beginner
mistake is that there's just simply not
enough conflict happening in the story
and um high stakes lots of conflict
that's what drives a story
so um you know it should something
should happen on page one yeah or the
conflict is only of one nature to me
that's the mistake of so many hollywood
studio films today that the conflict is
all external conflict
you know or the world is ending the
world is ending yeah you know so we need
the superheroes to come in
and and you know stop the bad guy but
you know that there's
all kinds of different levels of
conflict you know between human beings
there's a
psychological conflict between yourself
between you and and the gods or the
fates you know and
uh and and so the idea of what the
nature of the conflict in your script if
you only have external conflict coming
at your character
uh one kind of uh you know like like
literally like somebody just everybody's
throwing stones at them
then then this is a boring movie you
need to have all different kinds of
conflict
it needs to be yeah physical emotional
spiritual
every every type of yeah so story is not
something without conflict you know
stories about conflict and and the
essential conflict in a story
by the way is the the conflict between
what
a character wants and what they need
so you know the character says i want to
be
an astronaut they need to be somebody
who can be
dependent uh you know interdependent
with other people
so the movie ends the story ends when
those two things meet
when when their want becomes their real
need so their want begins to transform
and it's like
it's not about being an astronaut that i
should want it's this thing
as soon as a character wants what they
really should want
the story's over but that kind of trying
to get those two things to converge
what they want and what they need that's
the fundamental conflict of any movie
and when a main character gets what they
need that's typically a happy ending
when the main character gets what they
want that's typically a tragedy
you